today we have Peter Reinhart he's the
CEO of segment one through YC when 2011
and Sigma is doing extremely well peter
is going to talk about product market
fit sort of this magic concept word
people use only to really understand it
certainly the first job to get right and
any startup Peter thank you very much
for coming to talk to us and look
forward to hearing this all right so I'm
going to talk about finding product
market fit today we're segment is a b2b
company so that's probably why none of
you have ever heard of us but just give
you a little sense we're about a hundred
and fifty people and grew from about
four people three and a half years ago
so growing quickly and hopefully I can
shed some light on finding product
market fit for you I thought just start
by sort of looking back to Alan Kay's
lecture last week I think you had some
pretty incredible advice around how to
do really amazing research by sort of
looking into the future and imagining
what that future might be like and in
particular you have this diagram of sort
of exploring the pink plane and sort of
testing out different ideas there and
then at some point having a breakthrough
and realizing that actually there's a
blue plane right and you can sort of go
explore an entirely new space and that
that's like a key breakthrough for a
sort of understanding how you can really
invent that future and in particular he
had this idea of sort of going into the
future and imagining yourself there so
we had this Wayne Gretzky idea of
skating to where the puck should be or
will be and sort of going there grabbing
that future and then pulling it back to
the present and the way that he talks
about doing this is I think amazing for
research he talks about basically going
and sort of imagining that future world
but I'd actually wagered that a not a
single successful company has actually
been founded by doing that I think
that's we're getting awesome for
research but when it comes to founding
companies it actually has nothing to do
with sort of imagining your vision for
the future and what that future could be
it's not about sort of what how you wish
the world was but it's actually about
what customers want and I think a lot of
companies get marketed post-facto
of like hey we had this great idea and
here's how we deductively logics out
like what customers were going to want
and then we built the thing but in
reality that's not how it works at all
right in reality it's a very inductive
process you're going back and forth with
customers
and you eventually find something that
works and so I wanted to talk a little
bit about that process today and just
how critical it is and actually how
difficult it is to so one of the most
common mistakes that startups make is to
build something that no one at once
write or solve problems that no one has
and so that Wayne Gretsky method for
sort of going into the future and
imagining what that future might look
like again it's a good idea for research
it might even be a good idea for venture
capitalists to sort of imagine what the
future is like and sort of sort of put
startups into different buckets of what
building that future might look like but
actually think it's a really bad
strategy for founders and the reason is
that most founders can actually pretty
easily build something that looks like
it's from the future or is from the
future to some extent like it's easy to
solve the technology problem there but
it's actually really difficult like
that's not really what you need to do
right you don't need to build something
that is your vision of the future you
actually need to solve a specific
problem that customers have today here
now and most startups actually fail to
do that most startups actually build
something that looks vaguely futuristic
but is not in fact a real problem that
people have today and it will kill the
company every time right the market
always win so we're going to dig into
that a little bit more and this sort of
problem of finding product market fit is
that 80% 80% of all founders failed to
find product market fit so four out of
five attempts to find a company just
fail at this sort of earliest stage of
even finding a problem that you can
solve in a unique way
and the last one out of five we're going
to sort of struggle through the
remainder of actually building that
building that company up from there but
that's just the stat I'll share our own
story of finding product market fit but
the short version is that it actually
fuels when you're not finding product
market fit it feels like sort of a
bottomless emotional freefall not to get
too dark but when you're feeling to find
it it sort of becomes a strange
obsession and it could really make you
sick actually to get a little too
personal for a second in 2012 in the
midst of our search for product market
fit
I lost ten pounds in three weeks and
then went to the hospital twice for
panic attacks I haven't had a panic
attack before or since then and I think
it's not just me actually I think Sam I
don't know if I should show this or not
but when he was founding Luke I think he
basically forgot to eat properly and
ended up with scurvy if I remember
correctly seems like there somewhere
so basically be warned like finding
product-market fit is like very
emotionally a grind and the reason it is
is that you really really desperately
want to find that fit right you really
want to figure out what is going to work
what is something that customers want
we're all like wired to want to succeed
and help people like that and so you're
so intent on finding this thing that you
sort of convince yourself into seeing
mirages of it and basically you convince
yourself like oh this is the thing we're
almost there it's like this is something
that people really want and so this is a
picture of myself with my three
co-founders Illya Calvin and Ian in the
summer of 2012 I think and this is in
the midst of sort of our deepest false
hopes that we had found something so
we'll dive into that story and obviously
I'm here today because it worked out I
wouldn't be speaking if we had just
disappeared into the into the darkness
but yeah today we're about a hundred
fifty people in and growing rapidly yeah
make sure you find the big market we're
not just a role that we're not both yes
APD's advice on this is good and valid
which is it's actually harder to find
the first problem and solve any problem
well than it is to find like a route out
so finding a route out from some initial
foothold into a broad market is actually
not that hard sounds hard but like once
you find any foothold you can pretty
much find something and I can I can
cover that a little bit in a bit yeah
yeah a long haul a process where those
bringing you more problems right like
the most efficient thing for them to do
is just say like well I have this other
problem that's also adjacent to it can
you solve that yeah I'll go sure when
you solve that
you just keep solving adjacent problems
so once you find one thing it's actually
almost trivial to find the next thing
and the next thing in the next thing
especially in a selling to other
businesses where you have something
who can just tell you more stuff much
harder and consumer I'm the wrong guy to
talk to you about consumer stuff I don't
get it cool so but back then we were
just four dudes in an apartment we're
failing to find product market state we
were convincing ourselves that maybe we
had it or we were on the cusp of it and
we were writing a lot of code I saw
someone back there was writing code
earlier we were writing a lot of code
and we had no customers that's the wrong
order of operations and so we're
tricking ourselves into this and in
reality what the good thing that was
going on here the reality was that we
were a bunch of cockroaches and the
reason is that it's very important free
product market fit to basically save as
much cash as possible spend as little as
possible and extend your runway as long
as possible so a lot of founders make a
mistake of spending a bunch on sales or
marketing or other things as soon as
they have an idea but in reality until
you find product market fit until you
find something that people want you
shouldn't be spending any time on that
you should just be spending time talking
with customers and iterating and you
really want to constrain your runway or
constrain your burn so that you can have
a really long runway so that's what we
did we kept a burn really low I think we
paid ourselves like the minimum
allowable amount by law which was like
20 or 30 K year we lived in our
apartment slash office and like the
company paid for part of it as an office
like it was the minimal thing and we
stretched out our runway as through as
many ideas as we could and so to sort of
make this process a little bit more
explicit step one is that you build
launch and sort of iterate on several
different ideas and this is where it's
really important to be a rich we're
sort of conserving everything you have
then suddenly something magical happens
we'll talk about that and this is
product market fit and it really does
feel magical hopefully I can illustrate
the you and help you feel that and then
three product market fit sort of
suddenly turns you into a unicorn slash
cockroach and rather than just surviving
after product market fit everything gets
suddenly easier right you can not easy
but easier customers show up and buy
your thing people want to join your team
you're still pushing the boulder uphill
if you will but you're not totally
constrained on progress right you can
actually feel forward momentum for the
first time it's not like one step
forward at the product idea full step
back when a customer doesn't care
you actually can keep iterating on a
product that's starting to work so let's
take that middle portion and let's be
constructed a little bit so first we're
going to deconstruct what we call
category leaders so these are like
really large companies that have been
very successful and then we'll get to
sort of the heart of like why product
market fit is so important at the very
beginning and then we'll talk about what
bad fit feels like bad product market
fit and then we'll talk about what good
product markets it feels like and we'll
try to do that through stories because I
want the goal here is for you to walk
away and be able to more easily identify
which is which with your own ideas so
category leaders the reason we care
about category leaders is that they're
much much larger than basically the rest
of the companies out there so I'll give
you an example Amazon and Facebook are
sort of consumer companies that you
might be familiar with Salesforce is a
company that sells to other businesses
they provide sales software basically
and the reason that we're interested in
them is that they're huge right
they're often ten or a thousand times
larger than the next competitor in the
space so Salesforce for example you
probably heard of Sugar CRM and Zoho are
probably companies you've never heard of
they all do roughly the same thing and
so we want to dig into how can you build
a category leader what's the like layer
underneath that and basically what it
comes down to is building a platform
where it's not just a product that
you're selling but where the data inside
of your product is actually useful for
other businesses to build their business
on top of yours and that's what
Salesforce has done that's what amazon
has done that's what Facebook has done
and so if you look at Salesforce they
have something called the app exchange
and the app exchange sort of reveals the
all the data inside of Salesforce and
allows other companies to build
marketing and sales products on top of
that
similarly Amazon has the reseller
program right where now there's tons of
other businesses built on top of built
on top of Amazon and so the key here is
having some sort of platform eventually
when you get the scale having some sort
of platform
that other companies are building on
selling and by night by nature that
pulls people into your ecosystem so how
do you build a platform like that I know
Peter teal may not be the most popular
right now but his opinion is that to
build a sustainable and compelling
platform you really need to get to 100
million in revenue and the reason is
just that you need to be at a scale
where someone actually can capture a
couple percentage points of view of your
customer base and build a real business
themselves right so if they can capture
a couple percentage points say 2 to 3
million in revenue that's a real
business you can build something on top
of that so to sequence our way here you
want to build a category leader to do
that you need a platform to do that you
need 100 million in revenue so let's
keep digging 100 million revenue is
tough right so let's keep digging down I
think you met Jason Lumpkin a couple
weeks ago am i right and maybe he's
coming soon he's written some amazing
stuff about building software's of
service businesses would highly
recommend reading all his answers on
Quora and he basically breaks down the
path to 100 million in revenue in sort
of three different steps he says zero to
1 million is impossible 1 to 10 million
is improbable and 10 to 100 is
inevitable and he says that 10 to 100 is
inevitable because at that point there's
just so much momentum you have customers
out there who are singing your praises
they're buying their companies are going
to buy more and it might take you a
while but eventually you're going to get
from 10 to 100 1 to 10 million I think
is is basically always a brutal grind
for the founders and the reason is that
you're running a real business you have
real customers you have some scale your
customers have reasonable demands about
sort of how the quality of service that
they expect from the product but the
problem is that 310 million in revenue
you have a really tough time attracting
a world-class management team so you
can't hire a great exact team yet
because the like large enough market
isn't there and so what you have is
basically all the early crew sort of
like holding the ship together and
trying to make sure that it's going to
work that's a very tough period I think
for most founders to scale through and
then 0 to 1 million is impossible
because this is finding product market
fit and 80% or more of people fail at
that first step
so the question is how can you become
not and how can you actually make it
through that impossible section and
become one of the ones that succeeds and
one of the things that people talk about
as investors or founders is how
important it is to learn from failure
and I recently read a pretty good study
talking about the stat of sort of actual
analysis of failure and success in
startups and finding product market fit
and basically the research shows that
you're actually no more likely to
succeed the second time around if you
fail the first time so if you fail in
finding product market fit the first
time your odds of success are still 20
or 22 percent the second time around but
if you succeed in finding product market
fit the chances of your success the
second time around go from 22 percent to
34 percent which is still miserable but
is at least 50 percent better and so
what I think that means is that there's
actually not that much information
encoded and failing to find product
market fit like you don't actually learn
that much but there's actually quite a
bit encoded in in feeling the success of
actually understanding what did work and
so to you know when we were struggling
to find product markets it in 2011 in
2012 I felt this really acutely like we
had failed multiple times at this point
but I didn't I still don't feel like I
really knew what I was looking for right
like what is this mystical product
market fit thing so frustrating and we
kept seeing glimmers of hope we kept
convincing ourselves that this side of
the other thing was like a visitor
chatting with us on our site or whatever
was a big deal or vaguely interested
sales prospect was was product market
fit and so without any positive product
market fit examples we didn't really
know what it looked like and so we could
sort of convince ourselves of everything
and the way I think about it now is I
really desperately if you imagine like a
machine learning model I had a bunch of
negative training set examples and I had
no positive training set examples and so
of course my machine learning algorithm
was like I don't know and so I'm not
going to walk through three stories
where I'm going to show you two examples
of failure actually five-ish stories two
examples of failure and then three
examples on the positive side of times
that we actually did feel product market
fit and again my goal is for you to
actually feel what this feels like
so that you
identify it in your own product so
today's segment is a customer data
platform but we actually started as an
education tool and it was actually
designed exactly for lectures like this
so this is us coding in our Mountain
View apartment in the summer of 2011 and
the idea was that as a professor
standing up talking to a class you have
no idea if anyone in the audience
actually understands what you're saying
and so we were students at the time at
MIT and Rhode Island school design and
we said we really want to do is give
students a button to push where they can
say I'm confused right where I get it
either one and the professor would see
this graph over time of how confused the
students were might be helpful to me
right now and so we built this we were
at hundreds of thousands of lines of
code it had like commenting and notes
and all sorts of crazy stuff and we
actually came to Stanford's campus we
convinced that made it even been in this
Hall convinced some professors who would
like run up to them after class this is
a picture from Berkeley we pounced on
this professor right after class and we
were testing for product market fit
right we were trying to convince a
professor like did you get any feedback
from your class during this class No
okay well we have a solution for you so
we were hustling to try to get people to
actually use this tool but we were
mostly sort of ignoring any test of like
real product market fit there and so
professors would agree to test it out
for a few lectures sort of out of pity
maybe for some students from MIT who
were trying to trying to help and so
basically we thought that this was
product market fit but it really wasn't
and I'll show you why because if you
stand in the back of the classroom and
look at what people actually had on
their screens none of them were using
the product right like people were using
all these different things is it that
same class at Berkeley the next week
moment I was horrifying and basically a
students the students are seen as
students open their laptops they all
went and did other things and so
basically putting a laptop into the
classroom was the most distracting thing
you could conceivably do so as you can
imagine this was pretty horrifying one
of the more embarrassing things that
could have happened to us we had just
raised 600 K coming out of Y Combinator
demo day and we had sold this vision of
like this is how the future of
classrooms is going to work right like
it's going to be digital it's going to
be online much as this is a MOOC at
cetera and it was a great vision but
again the market wins every time it
doesn't matter what your vision is it
matters what the market actually wants
and in this case the students didn't
care
right the students didn't actually get
that much value out of using the tool
and actually if you go back we should
have had an even earlier warning sign
which is that the professors didn't
really want to use the tool either right
when you go and talk to the professors
they would sort of out of pity like
agree to test it for a few lectures but
that is not the same thing as product
market fit where they're like holy crap
that solved this problem that I have and
so sort of bullying customers into using
your product is not anything close to to
product market fit even if they sort of
reticent Lee agreed to do it and I think
being dismissive of users and having
their clear vision of the future that
isn't necessarily solving a problem for
your customers is a pretty stunning
failure on our part and it's like a key
thing that founders do again and again
and again in their sort of search for
product market fit so then we had to do
the awkward thing which by the way is
the right thing of calling back all the
investors and saying this was like four
weeks after they'd signed the checks
right by the way it turns out this is a
terrible idea we're going to do
something else do you want your money
back
and in most of these cases the investors
did take our sorry did not take the
money back they said we invested for the
team I like go find another idea we
believed in you guys go find something
else so I said okay let's do it and we
were all committed very committed to
working together as a team of four
founders so we shut down the lecture
tool we went and sort of shut down all
the classrooms and then we went back to
the whiteboard and we said what is
something that is sort of interesting
here and we had always felt like we
should have been able to determine that
we didn't have product market fit that
the product usage wasn't there from our
actual data like the way that we
actually figured this out right was we
went and we stood in the classroom like
back where Sam is
and like looked at what was on all the
laptop screens and that was how we
figured out whether we had product
market fit or not but we should have
been able to do that with the data we
should have been able to just look at
the analytics and figure out not only
are people using it or not
but our anthropology classes using a
different than computer science classes
and so we decided to build basically an
analytics tool which it turns out as a
bad idea
in case anyone was considering that and
so the way that we approach this is have
how many of you have read the book Lean
Startup wow that's actually awesome
you all are way far ahead so as Lean
Startup talked about you want to get out
of the building and actually talk to
customers right so we read that right
around this moment and we were like okay
we're going to go out and talk to
customers so we did that and we tried to
validate our idea so we'd take people
out for coffee and we'd pull people
companies and sort of try to figure out
if they were interested in analytics
products and I'd say again and again
they were vaguely interested right and
they had willingness to meet and chat
with us and they said they wanted
product updates as things came out and
so we thought this must be it right this
must be a product market fit where
people are interested in what we're
doing again this is not product market
fit this is idle interest very very big
difference and so based on this sort of
idle interest we got very excited and we
spent about the next six months just
writing code so now this is in a new
office that's my co-founder Calvin and
Ilya as you can see there's lots of code
on our screen again wrong order of
operations and I had gone on one sort of
sales trip to visit potential customers
and they were all pretty happy with
Mixpanel in Google Analytics but they
had these sort of edge case features
that they were hoping that we could
solve and so I sort of tricked myself
into believing that these little edge
cases that we might be able to solve
were actually a really wide gap that we
could fill as a product and so I came
back and I would sort of pitch my
co-founders and we would keep sort of
believing that we were almost there if
we just shipped one more feature one
more thing we're going to get to product
market fit again that idea give you
another one we used lots of little
positive interactions like this you can
also read this not as a positive
interaction but every once in a while
some straight person would visit our
website and they'd open a chat this is
idle interest
hey what's segments and there's a
complete transcript of that website chat
chat
you can see it's 3:00 a.m. so we're up
late coding and you know this person is
interested so maybe this is product
market fit again this is not what it
looks like this is just idle interest so
it's now December 2012
we've been up this for about a year and
a half and we decided that something was
wrong right like clearly this was not
working and so we went back to to YC we
emailed Paul Graham and we said hey we
think we should catch up and sort of
explain what's happened over the last
year and a half ok great so we go this
is us in front of the old YC building
and we're walking around a little cold a
sack by YYC on Pioneer way we bring them
up to speed like oK we've spent half a
million dollars like here's everything
we've sort of been through over the last
couple years and as we're walking around
he comes to a stop
he looks at us and he says so just to be
clear you've spent half a million
dollars and you've nothing to show for
it totally accurate and super fair and
sort of like shocked us into like oh
yeah we got to do something and so
that was that was the moment where we
realized we had hit rock bottom but we
still had a hundred K left so we still
got one more shot right alright so that
was all the product market failure cases
now you're going to see some successes
but let's rewind let's go all the way
back to the first week of YC and in that
first week we had been like well we have
this classroom lecture tool and we
should have analytics on it right so we
looked at the different analytics tools
KISSmetrics Google Analytics mix panel
and we were looking at like what's
similar here and we saw basically they
have they have different graphs and
different api's but it's actually it's
actually the same data going into all
these tools is just they give you
different stuff out the other end and we
were like well we don't really want to
make a business decision here about
which tool we want to use so we'll just
solve the engineering problem because
we're engineers and we'll just build
some code that sends data to all three
and does this automatic translation so
we put one data point in it gets
translated into three API calls that go
out to all three services cool this was
like 100 lines of code in the hundreds
of thousands that we wrote right set
that aside then about four months later
it gets improved a little bit four
months late
or gets improved a little bit at that
point we are trying to sell our own
analytics tool right akin to Mixpanel
and Google Analytics and we keep
encountering the sales objection when
we're trying to sell it which is I
already have mixed panel installed I
don't really want to install your tool
it seems like a lot of work so my
co-founder Ilya has this great idea he
says what is we take that little library
road a year ago that we've totally
forgotten about and we add ourselves as
a fourth service that it can send data
to and then every time someone hits us
with that objection we hit them back
with the open source library and we say
ok great now you can try both in
parallel and we use it as like a growth
hack basically to get customers to start
adopting our tool ok great we start
doing that start sending it out people
start replying oh this is awesome I love
the library I'll definitely definitely
gonna use it few weeks later we follow
up hey we saw you're still not sending
any data to segments do like what's
going on and they're like oh well the
library is fantastic I just don't really
want to use your analytic service should
have taken note right then but few
months ago by people start starring this
on on github maybe gets up to it was a
big deal for us at the time like 30
stars and I think maybe there was one
pull request issued and then fast
forward some more people keep sort of
paying attention it's the first time
we've ever felt like pull like people
were just finding this thing and doing
something with it and so fast forward we
have this conversation with PG and the
next day we sit down and we're like
alright like we need a new idea right
and so my co-founder ian is like you
know what I have an idea remember that
in the analytics tree s libraries that
has been sort of like idling on github I
think that could be a big business and I
was like you've got to be kidding me
that's the worst idea I've ever heard
like first of all it's open source and
second of all its 580 lines of code so
who the heck is going to pay for that
right like how do you build a business
around that it makes no sense and so we
were like fighting and fighting and
fighting and I went home and I was
racking my brains like ok how can I kill
this idea it's really bad and like it's
gonna sink us we only have one more shot
and then so I came in the next day and I
was like alright guys here's we're going
to do we're going to build a landing
page gonna be an awesome landing page
beautiful we're going to put it up on
hacker news is going to
the product and I'll have an email
signup form at the bottom and we'll use
this to just test whether it's a good
idea or not they agree okay great so I'm
like all right totally done we get ready
to launch it on Hacker News I'm starting
to think about other ideas and it goes
straight to the top so it gets about 300
up votes on hacker news gets a few
thousand stars on github
we have people reaching out to us on
LinkedIn demanding access to the beta
like this guy says what does the brother
have to do to get bumped up on your beta
list and there were others like this
right like like holy crap
so like full stop right like compare
this to everything previously like
everything changed this is what product
market fit looks like where it's like
not just a single metric like slowly
starts moving it's not just a few random
conversations where people express vague
interest right like literally every
single metric went totally haywire and
with our lecture tool and our analytics
tool we've been sort of searching in the
dark for like what features to build
next we did not have that problem
anymore right there were like thousands
of people who had signed up and they're
like you're seven integrations are good
but like I need these ten more and like
I'm deploying it tomorrow I'm like blah
blah blah blah blah we're like holy crap
like okay slow down and that's actually
one of the key things one of the key
things is that it flips from being
something that you're like pushing
against the customer to all the sudden
the customers like running away with it
and you're like wait but but like hold
on like wait it's not quite ready yet
and so another another example with our
analytics tool we had this sort of sad
unanswered questions and chats no one
really seemed to care about what we had
built but now all of a sudden we had
thousands of stars people working pull
requests we got like ten pull requests
in the first 48 hours or something like
that
and I guess the other key thing is with
our lecture to wonder analytics tool we
had had this huge vision right we had a
vision of like here's how the classroom
should operate or like here's how
companies should do analytics and then
we went about trying to build a product
that fit that vision but this was the
total opposite right this is like a
little tiny library that we built for
ourselves that solved a real problem had
no vision associated with it whatsoever
at the beginning now it does because we
have like a something that we really
want to go accomplish but at the
beginning it literally solved the
tiniest of tiny problems and so it's
your question earlier right like this is
that tiny little foothold and again like
it's an open-source library but 580
lines of code that's a foothold right
and since then now we've expanded
greatly into doing all sorts of things
and solving adjacent problems for
customers so the key is that again the
market doesn't doesn't care at all where
your vision of the world is the market
wants what it wants and it will win
every time so if you walk away with sort
of one thing today
I think it's let's be incredibly clear
that basically product market fit
doesn't feel like vague idle interest it
doesn't feel like sort of a glimmer of
hope from some early conversation it
doesn't feel like a trickle of people
signing up it really feels like sort of
everything in your business has gone
totally haywire there's this big rush of
adrenaline from customers starting to
adopt it and sort of ripping it out of
your hands and it really feels like the
market is dragging you forward I think
that Dropbox founders said this best
actually that product market fit feels
like stepping on a landmine and you
really you can't mistake the two so if
you are at all questioning whether you
have product market fit or not you don't
so obviously that didn't stop us from
making this mistake so just to make sure
that this is backwards no no it's not
all right so I thought class metrics for
sure had product market fit right big
vision market said no like market
doesn't care what you think
I thought segment i/o for sure had great
product market fit again market said no
market doesn't care market wins and even
on our third attempt when we did find
product market fit I thought for sure
that like this is too tiny to matter
right but it actually solved a real
problem and the market demanded it and
sort of ripped it out of our hands and
either that goes to show sort of how
obtuse I am or how hard it is to
actually find product market fit people
wanting to pay for something that was
open source anomalous couple mattresses
screen question so make sure that the
open source library buy oh sorry the
question is why would someone pay
anything for an open source library
that's 580 lines of code
question it turns out that the open
source library by itself doesn't totally
solve the problem so the actual problem
that we found out that we were solving
after we launched it was that marketing
teams keep coming to engineering
departments and saying I just signed a
contract with ExactTarget an email
marketing tool or I just signed a
contract with Adobe analytics and here's
the docs an engineering team says what
the heck I have a road match like I
can't like I need to be executing on
this other thing I can't like do this
analytic implementation and so what
really needed to happen in sort of what
analytics Jess could solve the problem
that we could solve at the hosted
version was allowing engineers to do a
single implementation of collecting that
data once and then letting marketers
just push buttons in our interface to
send the data wherever they need it but
the open source library doesn't quite
solve that problem engineer solid 8 was
the right abstraction but if the
marketer needed a new tool and your ears
an open source version the engineer
still has to go compile it so in some
ways we got lucky right that the
open-source version is doesn't fully
solve the problem cool so I'm going to
steal gratuitously from Alan Kay's
slides again and I think finding product
market fit feels a lot like finding the
sort of blue plane when you're in the
pink plan and I want to give some other
examples of finding product market fit
after finding that initial product
marketed and sort of the key difference
from that initial breakthrough from what
Alan Kay was talking about is that
rather than removing yourself from the
world and trying to imagine what the
future is like you actually need to go
out into the world and research what
problems people really have but then
once you find that product once you find
that sort of blue plan then things
actually get enormous ly easier right
that blue plane is basically a foothold
into a totally new perspective and I
think Alan Kay talked about the value of
perspective and context so to get this
foothold into a new way of thinking
about the world a new way of solving
some problem for someone and so not only
do you know what good fit feels like but
you now are operating in sort of green
pastures and you're approaching problems
in ways that all the incumbents in the
pink plane don't think about the world
so I wanted to give you two examples of
finding product markets since that
initial
a win for us so short intro to what
segments does we basically help you
collect data from mobile apps and
websites we pull it up to segments and
we fan it out to all the different tools
that you need and that's all you really
need to know the one of the places where
we could send data it was Amazon s3
right so this is basically just a place
to put all your log files and we started
to notice that all of our business dear
customers were using this one
integration they were all sending their
data to s3 but like you have to do
something with the data once that you
don't just like collect log files like
you do something with log files and so
we're like what the heck is going on
here and so we went and visited five of
our largest customers in New York about
three years ago and we said okay you're
using the s3 integration but what the
heck are you using it for and for five
out of five customers in a row they said
well we have a data engineering team
that's taking data from the s3 buckets
converting it into CSV files and
managing all the schema translation and
then uploading it into a data warehouse
like redshift and the creates the first
time I heard that from a customer I said
okay that's interesting and I took into
went to the second meeting customer said
exactly the same thing that's weird
okay taking the third conversation I was
like all right this is getting
ridiculous
like did you guys talk ahead of time or
like what happened here and by the fifth
time it's like okay well like obviously
I know we need to build right we just
need to build a connection from this
straight to redshift so then the
question is we run and built that and
just to show you now sort of now we have
a company that axes here in millions of
dollars in revenue and so we have a real
product that real people are using and
so what does product market fit look
like at that point right so we're
introducing a second product basically
well it looks like this right so you can
tell when we introduced redshift and
basically again almost every metric in
the business goes not right so it's very
very clear whether or not you have
something that it's really
transformative for your customers or not
one more one more story and then we'll
open it up for Q&A so this is maybe
about five months ago we had five ideas
for products that we thought might be
exciting to our
customer since I went to visit the
customer up large company up in the
Pacific Northwest and I sat down with a
data architects there and I said okay
here are the five ideas that I want to
run through and see if they're
interesting to you so I went through the
first idea and he was like yeah you know
what I totally get it that sounds super
valuable and I went through the second
one he's like oh that's really cool
that's cool you can do that like that
makes a lot of sense and then the third
idea fourth idea like same kind of thing
and so this is how I would summarize
that that like that's great I totally
understand what the value is means yeah
that would be great right like doesn't
care is what that is code for that's
someone being nice then on the fifth
idea I said hey here's what we can do
you know blah blah blah and he said wait
sorry you can do what and I react splain
dit and he said Oh interesting he turns
to his friend he says hey can you set up
a follow-up meeting with this team this
team in this team like we also need to
tell Joe about this because it like
could affect this other thing and like
like that again that is the feeling of
product market fit which is like you're
like wait no no it doesn't it doesn't
exist yet like these are ideas we might
like all of a sudden the customer is
just going to rip it out of you and so
now you're on a tight timeline because
the customer expects that it already
exists so again that's what product
market fit actually feels like and I
think if you want to find product market
fit and build one of these category
leading companies become one of the one
out of five founders that actually does
succeed in finding this I think you just
need to be really honest with yourself
that the sort of glimmers of false hope
that that you have are not the same as
customers actually ripping something out
of your hand and so yeah you just need
to be honest with yourself messenger so
questions
yes and I certainly agree in my
experience that that is without a market
that is like but what you're trying to
find it like have guidebooks for what
kind of ideas try when you just sort of
cast around looking for ideas actually
think the bigger problem is not
necessarily having the ideas I think
everyone has lots of interesting ideas I
think the bigger problem is not killing
the bad ideas fast enough I think
actually I've the most respect for the
Codecademy founders in this respect I
think they tried like 12 ideas and seven
weeks or something like that in the in
the summer of YC like something totally
absurd but they like legitimately tried
them and they killed them so fast and
then like four days before demo day they
started a new idea which was code
Academy and then it worked and on coke
atom II on launch day on demo day they
had like 300,000 users or something like
that right like again that's the
landmine effective like nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing and they
were so good about killing the ideas
they weren't like they had no problem
throwing out like something that wasn't
gonna work yeah I'm not sure I mean this
I don't think there's any magic to like
finding the right idea I feel like if
you just kill the bad ideas fast enough
you'll probably find something yeah a
little bit about pricing so this seems
like the e-billing I serve with 500
lines of code insulting you know a
significant relatively small like
significant to small film I don't know
if that's way to describe it how do you
go about pricing something like that
when you're doing that custom discovery
yes we did the question is like how do
you go about pricing something like this
where it's five hundred lines of code it
seems like it solves a small problem for
people we thought it was a small problem
for people and we underpriced hugely for
a long time it turns out that that
problem that we saw that you know the
five hundred lines of code solves is
actually really valuable like there are
come from we have lots of customers now
that pay over a hundred thousand dollars
a year to solve that problem and you
know there's more to the product now
than the five hundred lines of code a
lot more but it's nevertheless is the
size of the business problem has almost
nothing to do with the amount of code
written right and I think it did take us
a little while to like revalue things
and
respect but to answer your question most
directly we spent the first year just
accumulating customers so we just had
lots of people love adopting it got to
maybe like a thousand or 2,000 companies
sending data through segments and then
we tried experimenting with pricing and
then I'd say the biggest kick in the
butt we had to actually get to the right
point here as we had a sales advisor who
said we would go you know there were
reasonably sized companies using us like
like Live Nation and Rdio and stuff like
that and so we would go to sales
meetings at these companies and the
field advisor would basically get me
pumped up ahead of time he'd be like
Peter you have to ask for $120,000 a
year and I'm like that's crazy
like what are you talking about and he's
like Peter if you don't ask $120,000 a
year I'm quitting as your sales advisor
well all right here we go right and so I
would ask I'd turn beet red and then
like they would negotiate it down to
like 18k here but if you keep doing it
eventually someone is like well that
seems reasonable so and you you have to
keep testing the value like that right
because you don't know how much value
you're delivering until you start asking
for money I think of a how did you do
over again I'd start asking for money
earlier and it'd be a lot more
comfortable with it like if you're
solving a real business problem people
are going to be happy to pay for it I'm
not sure I totally answered your
question but yeah how do you know that
you're asking the right people about
your product like would it like there
should there should maybe be just a
small shift and like who you should be
asking so you're not realizing like how
did you yes the question is how do you
know whether you're asking the right
people and how do you know whether you
should like slightly shift
who you're talking to versus shift the
product yeah this is actually why it's
so hard to find product market fit the
first time and why it's so much easier
the second time once you have some
product market fit because once you do
have a defined customer set that you
sell to you can pretty easily figure out
by going back to the same people whether
or not you're solving an adjacent
problem for them but it's really hard
the thing that makes it super hard at
the beginning is it's like like you have
two things and you can either slide the
product or you can slide the market by
talking to different people I'm not sure
that there's a magic rule to know when
to slide which but I
I think founders get slippery with
themselves like they aren't totally
honest with themselves about which thing
they're doing when so I think it's I
think it's most important just to
recognize that like okay if we make this
shift we are like shifting the audience
versus shifting the product because I
think otherwise you can shift the
product and the audience simultaneously
and think you're doing well but then
realize you're not I'm not sure that
there's like a slam-dunk solution to
that other than just being really honest
with yourself about which thing you're
moving when another question yeah so you
mentioned that like you that's like
we're trying to like find rockin market
said before you guys sign it there was a
lot of moment I like oh kill this
product kill this rock my called youth
in cars like people or your teammates
would be like all of people family
elective us in solving the next thing
but like when we like self - I like
whether you talked to us before right so
he was a pretty big difference between
finding that first product market fit
where you can like kill a product
immediately move to a totally new
audience like codecademy tried a whole
bunch of different stuff with a whole
bunch of like being a switching
audiences they went from like SMB to
like programmers to like like
restaurants like all over the place
later on when you actually are like
building a company around it and you
have product managers and each product
manager is sort of like searching for a
big break for you it's a little bit
easier in that you can't shift the
audience anymore the audience is fixed
and so now it's a it's a slightly more
straightforward problem for sort of
helping a product manager understand how
to go talk to customers and sort of
reveal what problems those customers
have and then actually solve them so
it's mostly training in that loop and it
comes from talking to either larger
customers or your best customers or
worse customers and sort of like trying
to push the boundaries around like the
core of very happy people have to like
what other problems you can solve for
them yeah when you talk to like your
customarily awesome like what's your
script
you basically just so the question is
what when you're talking to customers
and trying to sort of like understand
what the problems are what's the script
I think the biggest mistake is trying to
pitch your existing ideas like there's a
place for that right when you have some
product market fit and you want to test
some of these things but I think most
founders and certainly we made this
mistake early on of like pitching rather
than and trying to sell rather than
actually trying to understand what their
problems were so now when I talk to a
customer I just start by asking what
their business problems are right like
hey like person at retail company like
do you spend a lot on Facebook like oh
yeah we spend a lot on Facebook like oh
well like how do you measure whether
that spend is efficient or not like well
we don't really know okay well is that a
problem like yeah yeah that's a big
problem okay well like tell me why you
haven't solved it like well we haven't
solved it because like blah blah blah
and you just start like digging in to
like these problems and then you're
actually really set up to do a sale then
right you're like well I have just the
thing right and they're like holy crap
but but if you don't have a product yet
now you know exactly what can what
problem you can fix right so I think
it's more about listening and digging
than it is about like pitching an idea
finally talking are like how do you be
like hey there's my optimize this
company yeah questions having to find
these customers at the beginning it's
hustle it's just like emailing people
cold it's getting intros through
everyone you know it's like scratching
and clawing your way through your social
network and through introduction and
after you have customers in an area then
it gets easier because you have people
coming to you all the time mostly if
you're inbound and so then there's like
a steady stream of people to talk to but
the initial piece like that's why people
talk about hustle being such an
important founder quality is because
like no one's going to help you you just
got to go find them right LinkedIn
investors friends - whatever you can
claw together
yeah so at the beginning when you like
should for these customer lightly cook
emailing them like homemade minutes and
a comment percentage of people actually
contacted you the fashion is when you
cool the email customers like what
percentage of people come back to you I
don't remember that was a while ago very
low like single digits percentages maybe
and you're going to send a lot of emails
that are unanswered but that's the
nature of sales honestly if you're
selling in like a business-to-business
kind of environment you're going to send
a lot of emails that go unanswered like
sales is basically the exercise we get
in the door slammed in your face like
nine times out of ten right yeah yeah
what's your vision bullets like where do
you look in five years respect the
diagram so what we have today is
basically sort of stream processing so
we have both the ability to collect data
across a broad section of stuff here as
well as the ability to fan it out a
whole bunch of different places and so
what we want to do is basically provide
a platform that all of these tools can
build on top of super short version so
you can imagine basically every team in
a company needs access to customer data
and we want to become the platform on
which those tools are built whether that
email marketing or push notifications or
analytics or help desks or CRM S or
payment systems fraud detection cetera
all of those things operate on a core
set of customer data and that's the
customer data that already flows through
segment by nature of us being that
integration connection layer and so we
just want to expose that data to
partners to build on top of it so when I
talked about building a platform at the
beginning that's the next step for us